the dishes world famous but paella is
rarely served the way it's made in its
birthplace Valencia with snails chicken
and rabbit meat perhaps the most famous
version however is paya de marisco with
shrimp and octopus the arroz negro
variation likewise features small shrimp
but comes with black rice dyed using
octopus ink lapa pica here in Valencia
has been cooking paella the traditional
way for over a century
sanyo ka ba kia has been around here for
ages but it was the first people who
came here and tried pea who made it
famous around the world el mundo oh yeah
it wasn't us who gave the dish its
significance the foreign visitors for Al
probar la la la importancia more than 2
million tourists visit Valencia every
year its famed for its orange trees and
attractive Mediterranean location and
all year round mild climate the mother
assa beach and promenade are popular
haunts among visitors and locals alike
and a real in place to go for a bite to
eat is lepa pika valenciennes
traditionally eat paella on Sundays but
it served up here seven days a week
locals are proud of their paya and
insists that there's nowhere better to
eat it yo pienso que from Vienna be my
about it it's because of the favorable
climate for growing the vegetables we
use a better life ya know loving cookin
with these fresh ingredients including
the rice makes a difference Colin
pedagogy nada compared to that the
really soft water we have here that's
why the payer here tastes so good ela
rose sharply mejor this is how to make
that authentic aiea Valenciano you'll
need chicken and rabbit meat plus broad
green beans snails big gaurav on beans
and short grain rice plus tomato sauce
and olive oil
and don't forget the bell peppers and
saffron
fry the meat and vegetables and then
season deglaze with water and continue
cooking while stirring add the rice 20
minutes later your paella will be done
optionally you can save time by cooking
it in the oven at 180 degrees Celsius
people are finest of a meal out of it
Spain has a thousand different rice
dishes they will not off but with paya
the rice has to be firm you know the bit
of bite silo get together it should be
nice and fluffy and not overcooked or
sticky ethical thirtieth day and my
father peanuts with the people an old
mill in the east of the city is home to
a museum documenting the history of rice
plantations in Valencia it was in the
early 20th century that piyah had
involved in to what we know it as today
lapa a hundred one oh yeah is ritual una
urania me go for friends and family
gathered together especially on holidays
the preparation is a ritual as is eating
it so basically it's a day of
celebration Deanna Fiesta moveable feast
said lapa fika have been attended by a
range of luminary diners over the years
Ernest Hemingway used to come here after
watching bullfights Spanish opera singer
Placido Domingo is also among its happy
past clientele and former king of Spain
juan carlos has been here five or six
times always unannounced home agoria so
very aralia was it was funny because the
King wanted a pyre with chicken and
rabbit but the Queen wanted one with
vegetables so we made one for each of
them was life for you and then they
wanted a third player with seafood una
ropa pika hey fam parent the king ended
up each of the Queen's as well la mujer
porque es que no Grenada
whether with meat seafood or vegetables
aiea is a Spanish specialty that can be
eaten in all manner of variations all
over the world
you